in the last video about gideon off near
we went over how he could be the true
villain in the world of elden ring which
is sort of odd to think since he's the
leader of the round table hold and
seemingly tries to help us on our
journey to becoming elden lord feeding
us constant information about where to
go what to do next and who certain
characters are but in the end he tries
to stop us on that path he's the
all-knowing the all-hearing or at least
that's what he calls himself but how is
he the all-knowing how does he gather
all of this information to us it seems
like he never leaves the round table
until we see him in the ashen capital
city is he really just constantly
reading everything he can learn in his
study reading books on the history of
everything throughout the lands between
maybe he has some ability to gather
information quickly or has eyes and ears
all over the world in the last gideon
video we talked about how gideon uses us
to his advantage he feeds this
information about the demigods and where
to find them along with their great
runes just so he can try and steal it
all from us right before we reach the
door of the erd tree i call him the
villain of elden ring and i still
believe this to be true now calling a
character a villain is sort of pointless
as all of the characters in the game
including us have our own aspirations of
achieving our own goals and will clearly
do anything to fulfill our destinies if
you've only played through the game once
you likely wouldn't notice that during
gideon's boss fight his abilities can
have a wide range depending on where
you've ventured and which bosses you've
defeated if you've traveled to mogwin's
palace and defeated moak gideon uses
blood incantations related to moog's
moveset same goes as if you travel to
the haleuk tree and defeated melania
he'll use scarlet rot in our fight
against him but that's only if we've
traveled to those optional areas and
defeated those optional bosses now this
is a video game and we could just say
this is because we've reached the end of
the game and going up against a boss who
has a wide variety of attacks from
enemies we've encountered throughout the
game makes a lot of sense it would be
the culmination of everything we've
experienced in our play through so far
but don't forget that this is from
software and everything we do see and
interact with has a purpose some big and
some small but every situation has a
purpose and a deeper meaning so i
believe there's a reason that gideon has
these new attacks and that's because
he's likely been stalking observing or
spying on us during our journey every
time we enter a new area fight a new
enemy or defeat a boss gideon sees it
all and adds it into his wide range of
knowledge to eventually use it against
us
for his own benefit if we look at this
still image in the opening cutscene we
can see gideon lane in a coffin filled
with eyes and ears considering he is the
all-hearing and all-knowing this
branding of eyes and ears is very
fitting i also have this small theory
that the painter we interact with
throughout the game is the person who
painted these opening cut scenes there's
basically nothing that proves this i
just like to believe this to be true i
just think some of the images that we
see in the opening cut scene are
exaggerated in some ways and as an
example having gideon in a coffin filled
with eyes and ears this could be where
he woke up as a tarnished or it's just
an exaggerated painting by the painter
that we see throughout the game that's
just my little theory take it or leave
it but the all-knowing armor set
continues to showcase this brand with
eyes on the midsection and stacks of
ears outlining the bottom this armor set
reads armor set with countless eyes and
ears worn by gideon off near the
all-knowing knowledge begins with the
recognition of one's ignorance the
realization that the search for
knowledge is unending so gideon is
representing what he wishes to be the
all-knowing the name gideon of near
could potentially come from two
different references if we look into
norse mythology of near is one of the
many nicknames given to odin who is
known as the all-knowing of the norse
gods who would use the eyes of ravens to
spy and gather information the name
gideon could also come from a species of
beetle known as xylotropes gideon when
seeing this i immediately think of the
crimson tier scarabs which while looking
like a certain type of beetle also has
an image of an eye seemingly drawn onto
it some of these beetles have different
images of drawings on them but i've also
noticed these beetles change form and
size and when they do this that image
changes back to the insignia
of an eye which i believe references
gideon the next step in looking into
gideon would be looking at the
description of items that have this
symbol while none of the scarab
descriptions reference gideon the i
surcoat armor set reads brown circo
draped over chainmail the insignia
emblazoned on the front marks out the
wearer as the eyes and ears of sir
gideon the all-knowing this tells us
that gideon uses this insignia to label
his spies that he can use to gather
information from all over the lands
between just like how odin uses ravens
gideon uses these beetles to spy on us
and our journey to obtain information
without putting himself at risk it's
possible he needs to label these beetles
with this eye insignia for him to be
able to spy or observe because labeling
things you intended to use as spies is
pretty counterintuitive or gideon just
doesn't care that we know he's watching
us since he does try to help us as well
with these beetles since they drop
valuable items for us to use i believe
some of these beetles are native to the
lands between but are used by gideon to
obtain as much knowledge as possible so
he can truly be all knowing or as close
as he can to that but there are certain
areas where gideon's beetles are either
scarce to find or just are not there at
all there are no beetles in mogwin's
palace the halak tree the deep root
depths and very few at the mountaintops
of the giants now it's important to note
that gideon is just known as the
all-knowing think of it like a nickname
it doesn't mean he knows everything in
fact he asks us to tell him if we learn
anything new and he rewards us for doing
so this new information that we can tell
him just so happens to be info on moog
and mogwin's palace oh so that's where
the so-called lord of blood was hiding
himself eh
a fitting little squad for that deluded
maniac to bleat about the revival of his
precious dynasty
while he turns our fellow tarnished into
bloody fingers
let him stay there
that way his delusions will remain as
they are distant and unattainable but
perhaps it's worth looking into
if what i've heard is right then
maybe
ah
my apologies
lost myself for a moment there
and we can also give him new information
on the haley tree and mykola after
defeating melania so
the hayley tree
now butter husk
i heard speculation mikala embedded
himself in the hayley tree
but
before he could finish
someone cut the tree open and absconded
with his infant phone
indeed
it seems those words held weight
how vexing
that they all knowing didn't have the
full story perhaps the queen's sort of
was justified
ah
my apologies
lost myself for a moment there
one thing you may be asking yourself is
why are there different images on the
scarabs if he was using them to spy on
us wouldn't he just use one type of
insignia now this is just speculation on
my part but i mentioned briefly earlier
these insignias sometimes change from
one image back to the eye on certain
scarabs i believe gideon massed some of
these spying beetles in an attempt to
trick us or steer our suspicions of
gideon using these beetles to watch and
observe us it wouldn't be the first time
he tells us one thing in order to make
us think one way and then flip it
against us the greatest example of this
is when we fight against him up to this
point it's kind of already known that
gideon is seemingly watching our
progress through the lands between it
doesn't seem like he's trying too hard
to hide this and i thought maybe he was
just too old or too weak to go out into
the world and fight against these
monstrosities and powerful demigods that
we fight against but i started to think
otherwise when i looked deeper into what
gideon was causing gideon slaughtered
these people in the village of the
albanorics in order to find the secret
medallion to the haleg tree we can learn
more from albus a surviving albanoric
disguised as a pot we're finished
the whole village is finished
the coast mongers have destroyed
everything
no one that remains has their wits about
them
i beg you
would you look after this medallion
you must keep it out of the curse
manga's hands and if you should meet the
young albino reclintena
then please give it to her
when we find latina near this area she
tells us more of what gideon did here
killing her wolf lobo in search of the
medallion fell tarnished
what do you want
i told the all-hearing brute that i
possess no such medallion or have you
come to take more from me was my other
half not enough
and when his adoptive daughter hears
what gideon has done she confronts him
only to be cast aside as he has no need
for her anymore and i
can no longer trust him father
to think he'd ordered his men to enact
such tragedy where is the justice he
departs in that
he once told me that if he became eldon
lord
he would never allow the downtrodden to
be cheated ever again
was he simply lying to me
he also more than likely tries to kill
us after we obtain the first half of
this medallion having his bodyguard
insha attack us when we return to the
round table hold with it after we kill
insha gideon then tries to blow it off
as insha acted on his own even though he
references that insha got ahead of
himself when attacking us indicating
that killing us was a part of the plan
just at a later date oh my apologies for
that nasty business
and she got rather ahead of himself it
seems
as his master
i'd like to express my regret
but now
and she is slain and gone
finished
forevermore
what we can take from this is that
gideon is ruthless in his quest to
become elden lord killing or casting
aside those who defy or question his
pursuits of knowledge but the questions
still stands as to why he tries to stop
us you could think at this point that he
has to stop us before we reach the
urgery and seek an audience with queen
merica if he doesn't stop us here then
we have the best chance of becoming
elden lord and we've known from the
start that he himself wants to become
elden lord i am known as gideon of near
as a tarnish who wishes to stand before
the elden ring and become elton lord
i am accumulating knowledge
to be
all-knowing
this was likely his intentions from the
start of our journey but as time went on
those intentions changed after looking
into queen america's plan we can see
this when we read further into gideon's
armor set which reads but when gideon
glimpsed into the will of queen america
he shuddered in fear at the end that
should not be and when we meet him in
battle before the queen's bedchamber he
not only wants to stop us but to stop
anyone including himself from becoming
elden lord ah
i knew you'd come to stand before the
elden ring
to become elden lord
what a sad state of affairs
i commend your spirit but alas
none shall take the throne queen america
has high hopes for us
that we continue to struggle
unto eternity
if you want more information on queen
america's plan at least my
interpretation of it go watch my video
called queen america's perfect plan her
plan to put it bluntly wants us to try
to become elden lord but we must first
earn that right through proving
ourselves as the strongest by fighting
against the strongest and mending not
only the elden ring but proving that we
can fix the lands between as well and
can control the greater will with all
this said i still can't figure out if
gideon just let godfrey go ahead of him
or he just hadn't reached him yet and
instead waited to kill us before him
which would sort of go against what he's
been doing since the start of the game
using us to do most of the hard work in
killing the demigods and obtaining their
great runes to mend the elden ring back
together but gideon doesn't believe that
a man or a tarnished can kill a god
i know in my
bones
a tarnished
cannot become a lord
not even you
a man
cannot
kill
a god
godfrey is known as the first tarnished
banished from the lands between by queen
america herself to battle and become
stronger in lands far away so at least
from what he says when we kill him
gideon doesn't think even godfrey can
become elden lord so this could be why
he tries to stop us first before moving
on to try and stop godfrey as well
gideon still is in my opinion
one of the most villainous characters in
all of elden ring but of course everyone
in the lands between seems like a
villain maybe he's just misunderstood
maybe he's just been manipulated maybe
queen merica cast a curse on gideon to
just turn on us in such a hard way all
of these speculations are possible but
we just don't know for sure nor are we
supposed to know everything either way
gideon makes me very uncomfortable in
regards to everything we've talked about
and especially
after hearing this piece of dialogue
regarding ronnie tarnished a word
i hear you conspired with ronnie the
witch
i understand
the need for puppet gosh is strong
do you think i've not felt it
in my quest to be all knowing it
i too have known the draw to the blue
connie
with their forearms
think of all the things that she can do
to it
your tarnished tackle
and then
imagine 10 more
just
tell me this
when she was miniature in your grasp
did you
stick her in a jar
and did you
fill that jar with your tarnished seed
i'd do the same if given the chance
be on your way then
to the capital
thank you all for watching the video and
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already my goal is to get my percentage
of subscribers to viewers ratio up to 50
by the end of the year right now we're
at 12
which considering this percentage was at
2 just over a month ago we are
definitely on the right track thanks
again everybody and i will see you all
in the next video take care